quand on a mal quelques vents il tiens
je suis encore vivant
l'humour juif dans sa plus
extraordinaire expression Joseph wesmann
est un miraculé l'un de ces très rares
rescapés de la rafle du Vél d'hivan
juillet 1942 un épisode dramatique qui
concourera la mort de ses parents et de
ses deux soeurs à Auschwitz sa vie a
fait l'objet du film l'arabe et vient
d'être illustré dans cette récente bande
dessinée en 1996 à Orléans il avait
rencontré Simone Veil qu'il avait
exhorté à témoigner de sa poignante
histoire depuis il va de ville en ville
pour livrer son dramintime chaque
témoignage c'est vrai me fatigue
davantage c'est à chaque fois l'enfant
de 11 ans qui revient qui souvenir
douloureux tout et quand je le faisais
que j'avais 60 ans et que je le fais
aujourd'hui par exemple voyez quand je
vais repartir je suis incapable de
conduire ma voiture
parce que je me vide dans un
contextermination on arrive comme mes
parents aimaient de sœurs sont arrivés
et sont tout de suite passer à la
chambre à gaz ils sont morts tout de
suite et ensuite au four crématoires la
réalité du génocide cru abrupte y
compris face à un auditoire de collégien
Joseph wesmann élue de rien il dit le
désespoir lorsque les gendarmes français
l'arrachent au bras de sa mère à l'âge
de 11 ans il dit la force le courage
l'inconscience peut-être lorsqu'il
s'évade du camp de Beaune-La-Rolande
quelques semaines plus tard on est passé
au pied d'un mirador comment ça se fait
que le gendarme
il est intervenu il est midi on est au
mois d'août il fait très chaud il dort
deuxième hypothèse la densité était-elle
d'épaisseur des barbelés qu'il était
incapable de nous voir au fond et la
troisième hypothèse qu'on veut retenir
si il nous a vu mais il a pas voulu nous
voir
Joseph wesmann sera plus tard recueilli
par une famille de la Sarthe auprès de
laquelle il attendra en vain le retour
de ses parents aujourd'hui à 91 ans il
devrait se reposer s'occuper de ces six
petits enfants mais un devoir de mémoire
le harcèle constamment
je me traiterai de lâche si je disais
bah écoute écoute ça suffit comme ça va
à la pêche et laisser quand tu seras
plus là il faudrait non je peux pas je
peux pas